welcome to this video a new part of our
series on calculation and tactics yeah
in this Sun in this episode we are going
to look at a position very much
tactically rich position it does not
look so complicated at first so many
pieces on the body but both sides have
advanced passers
I just got poops on b7 like a pawn on f3
there was some definitely will be
important yeah it is why to move this
position is from a game of Allen versus
Nielsen 1968 pretty much unknown players
and yeah not so well known position I
guess
it is why to move and if you want to
treat this as a real exercise and not
only watch the video um you should
definitely pass the video and then take
your time it is not that easy unless you
are total genius you will take some time
to figure out the key lines um what
should Y do and it's not only human the
solution should not only be like you you
come up with the move and say wow that's
winning but it should also include on
some detail why certain other things
might not win well not as good so if you
really wanted to gain from this ban
benefit from this from this exercise you
should really calculate the whole yeah
the whole position and try to understand
what what are the best lines and why
other side FIRREA ok I'm going to beside
the couple of seconds so that you can
definitely pass this and set this up on
a board and that will continue in a
couple of seconds with the analysis of
the position ok now let's have a look at
this when we approach the analysis of
a position like that a very much um yeah
sharp position where there are direct
threats like f2 check or b8 wide can
promote we should definitely first get
an idea about what moves are possible at
all the so-called very famous candidate
moves principle that very often can vary
dramatically lower the effort that we
need to invest in the solution very
often you start to calculate something
very complicated and instead you have a
very simple solution available that what
you have looked for the move at all you
would have seen rather quickly so here
why does very close to the promotion of
the point in fact he can promote on move
one we look at this this is a line we
must consider definitely in our
calculation what else can we can we look
at white also could argue that this pawn
is promoting anyway what should like do
him if white is playing a defensive move
yeah defense against what f2 is an
obvious threat what in fact if you look
at this can make a defensive move and
try to simply you hidden the black from
doing this f2 move a very strong
continuation and one of the the the good
moves that you could have come up with
is rook f1 that's in fact very very
simple as f2 check is simply answered by
the caption another very good news when
this position is King f1 this move
simply goes out of this F to check idea
preventing the check those two moves
were the absolutely simplest solutions
however if we calculate we also must
check b8 Queen
and if you in your analysis only looked
at the rook f1 and King f1 and didn't
really bother to calculate this then
that much then that still would like you
to to try to adjust the consequence of
b8 Queen because of the upcoming
complications are very interesting so I
might as well pause the video again and
look at this position it's all about f2
check of course what happens after f2
check yeah white played this actually in
the game b8 Queen f2 check King f1 and
here it was necessary to see the next
move what is blacks only possible way to
even continue the game it's clear that
if black takes on one with check we
recapture and then black has nothing
special against the white king there is
not much damage else than this this
capture and then white would simply even
promote the a pawn and simply is a
complete rook up very easy win
so it's this so simple
after King f1 black has no resource him
in fact he has hip like has a very very
nice move and this is Bishop g2 check a
very very nice resource can because the
bishop now White has only two moves of
course you can take with the king or you
can take with the rook
a very nice variation here is King takes
g2 after King takes g2 now black has a
very nice response if you saw this when
you look at b8 Queen my congratulations
because this is not easy to do here
black has the fantastic move f1 check
double check in fact
yes the rook and the Queen so white can
only capture and now black plays rook F
to Jack just fantastic yeah basically
out of nowhere
Black has managed to stand mate create a
stalemate yeah it's absolutely amazing
those rooks take away squares and the
Queen from b8 far where take takes away
the f4 square and the Silla porn f6 so
fantastic stalemate White has no way to
escape it if you look at this you can
still give up the rook and still give it
up this is the same thing it's just a
drawn fantastic so Bishop g2 is a
fantastic resource in fact in this
position white instead of them taking
with the king he could have taken with
the rook rook takes f6 e1 no there's
nothing else F takes G one King takes
rook takes me eight and in this position
white still has a winning continuation
it's not so difficult actually you play
a seven attack the rook the rook needs
to block the pawn and then we play rook
a 2 which is following the well-known
rule that the rook is optimally placed
behind the pawn supporting the person
this is a completely a winning endgame
we can if you like and continue a bit
something like this it's the key idea
the H pawn will also be pushed dr king
g5 King f3 King takes King f4 something
like this is the way it will happen and
then the white king is coming over and
will help to promote the pawn
so if we go back all the way
this means that Bishop g2 was being a
great move is still losing with rook
takes from g2 White can still win but
only in the endgame in the game here
actually the actual game they had to
stalemate on the ward so why did he took
with the King and he didn't consider
Jack those great sacrifices to secure
the draw this means if we go back all
the way to the starting position
white in fact has three moves on there
are even more actually has a couple of
moves that win b8 also wins but only if
you really have had seen this is this
point with with a stalemate idea another
move here for white that that also wins
is Ruby 7 by the way it's a little bit
less obvious then then rook f1 yeah look
f1 is probably the easiest way to do it
as no f2 is completely out of the
picture after Luke is 7 likes we can
gives a check and here he's running out
of ideas it looks a bit dangerous at
first because any check now would be
almost made but black has no ways to
check white and there is still this b8
Queen coming
so if white is making a prophylactic
movie on the first in the initial
position he can save himself lots of
work like rook f1 when I looked at this
position I was once on the that's a
receiving end of this position trying to
to solve it is white my pretty quick
suggestion was look at one end and uh
that's it I didn't even bother to
calculate b8 so much because Luke f1
stops all the other ideas but this this
line b8 Queen F Chang is just
great okay so understanding yeah I hope
you enjoyed this position and maybe use
it as a calculation exercise it shows
that sometimes prophylactic moves can
easily help to yet make life make life
much easier
you need to calculate a much less
intense less danger of making a mistake
but that also shows that there are
sometimes absolutely amazing resources
and positions that look totally lost
like here the staying metric hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching